i'm so excited that she has come here
today
bethany frankel oh oh
you over there hi by the way could you
look any more beautiful flowers flowers
flower oh my goodness i've dressed for
the part
i always tell that to my daughter like
you know because her grandparents they
like love you know they're a little
fancy and they
i'm like you know elastic sweatpants and
just bad
and um i always tell the girls they're
so lucky because they're gonna find
their own journey i'm like you might
like
actually dressing up or you might like
being you know kind of
piggy like me but i like that i get to
dress the part at work so i get that out
of my system
that's the reason and but i always say
dress the part because it is there's
something that changes
your demeanor about i agree and i'm
always in pajamas 99 pajamas but that's
one of the reasons that i like to work
because it gives me a reason to get out
of my pajamas and actually bathe myself
so you work so hard on so many things
and before we go to commercial i would
love to talk to you about
the podcast and we're going to talk
about that again more but
what side of bethany frankel do we get
because you have so many okay
i do have many and i did climb um my own
everest last night at domestic everest
i had a glass of wine a martini and a
margarita
so i made like a long island tea with
that was my big contribution last night
to survive um
so the podcast is called just be with
bethany it is out right now it is
literally right now you can
access it it dropped it my album dropped
and nobody that i know that are my
friends knew how to
subscribe to a podcast much less listen
to what including myself so
for everybody over 79 it's there but
we're we're beating hillary clinton i
mean
it's not like she hasn't accomplished
anything i mean so yeah we're powerful
women
yes i'm excited sharing like but you
have we're not sharing i'm beating her
right now okay
so but no hillary when you're uh doing
the debate tonight check that out
um and uh i'm just you have so much to
offer
in an entrepreneurial advice
in fact we're going to go to commercial
because i have a surprise for you okay
and then i'm going to tell you what it
is about and what bethany you're getting
exactly we'll do it exactly all right
yeah we have a little surprise for you
that's amazing congratulations i love it
already i could tell it's very you
it's very good i just get it and it's
smart so i'm congratulations
uh i'm gonna go pass out
and come back as the happy little lamb
that i feel like right now because
bethany approves and i have so much
respect for what you do
you